die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis ein schönen Sonntagabend
wünsche ich Ihnen für den Sport mit
dabei ist Norbert König ja sehr gerne
guten Abend als erstes schauen wir auf
eine griechische Urlaubsinsel
Ausnahme Situation auf Rhodos wegen der
Waldbrände müssen tausende Menschen
fliehen darunter viele Touristen
Protestmarsch erreicht Jerusalem in
Israel haben die finalen Beratungen über
die Justizreform begonnen
und Spannung vom Spiel gegen Marokko die
deutschen Fußballfrauen steigen morgen
früh in die WM ein
[Musik]
die Waldbrände auf der griechischen
Insel Rhodos sind mittlerweile so stark
und außer Kontrolle geraten das
zahlreiche Dörfer und Hotels evakuiert
werden mussten rund 19.000 Menschen
wurden mit Bussen und Schiffen in
Sicherheit gebracht oder es ist die
viertgrößte Insel Griechenlands 35 km
breit und 80 km lang die Brenda strecken
sich von Platania bis nach kyotari mehr
von Andreas poste
plötzlich muss alles ganz schnell gehen
nachdem die Feuer auf Rhodos außer
Kontrolle geraten sind wechselnde Winde
treiben die flammenrichtung Hotelanlagen
in kyotari auch Familie Stein mit ihren
zwei kleinen Kindern wird aufgefordert
zum Strand zu laufen wir müssen unser
ganzes Gepäck zurücklassen weil direkt
der Notfall Alarm halt ausgelöst worden
ist dass ein Feueralarm und
in dementsprechend sind halt direkt
geflüchtet ne an den Strand sie nehmen
nur die wichtigsten Dinge mit an ihrem
letzten Urlaubstag kommen sie sogar mit
dem regulären Rückflug nach Frankfurt
zurück und mit dem Schrecken davon
19.000 Menschen werden offiziellen
Angaben zufolge aus 12 Dörfern und
sämtlichen Hotels in den betroffenen
Regionen der Insel in Sicherheit
gebracht Touristen aus aller Welt
verbringen die Nacht in Not und der
künften Turnhallen einige auch unter
freiem Himmel
das ist die größte Evakuierungsaktion
zur Sicherheit für Einwohner und
Touristen die jemals in unserem Land
durchgeführt wurde
das griechische Außenministerium hat am
Flughafen ein Informationszentrum
eingerichtet und Touristen
unbürokratisch bei der Ausreise zu
helfen außerdem gebe es eine Hotline zur
Information für Angehörige die Feuer auf
Rhodos sind offenbar nur schwer und der
Kontrolle zu bringen die langanhaltende
Hitze und starke Winde erschweren die
Löscharbeiten zusätzlich ein großer Teil
der Insel war zeitweilig ohne Strom
mehrere Reiseveranstalter haben
Urlaubsreisen nach Rhodos storniert im
griechischen Urlaubsparadies gilt nach
wie vor die höchste brandwarenstufe
CDU-Chef Friedrich Merz hatte im
zdf-sommer-interview eine Verbot der AFD
abgelehnt
parteivverbote haben noch nie dazu
geführt dass man ein politisches Problem
löst so märz in der Flüchtlingspolitik
setzt der CDU-Chef auf einen schärferen
Kurs einzelheiten dazu von Winnie
hescher
wohin will Friedrich Merz die CDU
Steuern täglich kommen derzeit aus
seiner Partei schärfere Vorschläge zu
Migration das Asylrecht einschränken
Flüchtlinge an Europas Küsten
zurückweisen mehr Grenzkontrollen das
Problem muss kleiner werden und wir
müssen unseren
Menschenrechtsverpflichtungen auf der
Welt nach wie vor Nachkommen wir müssen
dabei bleiben dass wir ein Land sind das
auf der Welt hilft aber diese Hilfe darf
auch nicht missbraucht werden und sie
wird hunderttausendfach missbraucht und
dagegen müssen wir was tun
und die CDU muss etwas für sich tun denn
bis auf April diesen Jahres als sie die
30 Prozent im zdf-umfragen überschritten
hat kann sie nicht von der Schwäche der
Ampel profitieren es profitiert die AFD
die Brandmauer in Bund und Ländern
bekräftigt der CDU-Chef in den Kommunen
aber hält der Kontakte für möglich es
ist in Sachsen-Anhalt ein in einer
kleinen Gemeinde einen Bürgermeister
gewählt worden der AFD gehört angehört
und natürlich ist das eine demokratische
Wahl das haben wir doch zu akzeptieren
und natürlich muss in den
Kommunalparlamenten dann auch nach Wegen
gesucht werden wie man gemeinsam die
Stadt das Land den Landkreis gestaltet
Differenzierung auch gegenüber den
Grünen die hatte März zuletzt als
Hauptgegner in der Bundesregierung
benannt die CDU regiert in einigen
Bundesländern gut mit den Grünen
zusammen aber wir richten uns jetzt vor
allen Dingen in der Wirtschaftspolitik
gegen das was aus dem
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium kommt was
in der Klimapolitik in der
Energiepolitik passiert März will dass
die CDU als Alternative zur Ampel
wahrgenommen wird von der CDU als
Alternative für Deutschland mit Substanz
spricht er nicht mehr für diese Wortwahl
hatte er auch in der Union viel Kritik
erhalten
das vollständige ZDF soll man Interview
sehen sie gleich nach dieser Sendung
im sächsischen Sebnitz haben vier
teilweise maskierte Männer geflüchtete
in einer Unterkunft attackiert laut
Polizei traten sie die Hintertür ein
griffen mehrere Bewohner an und riefen
ausländerfeindliche Parolen erst als
weitere Anwohner hinzu kam flüchteten
die Täter ein 18-Jähriger Afghane wurde
verletzt der Staatsschutz ermittelt
in Spanien läuft seit heute morgen die
vorgezogene Parlamentswahl
Ministerpräsident Sanches muss um sein
Amt fürchten seit 2020 führt der
Sozialdemokrat eine Minderheitsregierung
in den letzten Umfragen lag aber hinter
dem konservativen Spitzenkandidaten
vecho dieser könnte zusammen mit der
rechtsextremen Partei VOX eine
Koalitionsregierung bilden
die Wahllokale sind noch bis 20 Uhr
geöffnet Thomas Walde in Madrid zum
ersten Mal findet eine Wahl in Spanien
der mitten im Hochsommer Stadt wie wirkt
sich das aus
die ungewöhnlichen Umstände tragen
durchaus zur Unberechenbarkeit bei es
herrschen derzeit hier noch 35 Grad im
Schatten um 18 Uhr lag die
Wahlbeteiligung bei 53 Prozent das sind
vier Punkte weniger als zur selben Zeit
2019 da ist allerdings die Zahl der
Briefwähler noch nicht eingerechnet und
die bewegt sich in diesem Jahr auf
Rekordniveau Petrus Sanchez hat versucht
bis zuletzt Angst zu schüren für eine
möglichen Rechtsruck hier im Land und
sein konservativer Gegenspieler Alberto
Junior von der PP der Volkspartei hat
zumindest nicht ausgeschlossen mit der
rechtsextremen VOX zusammen zu arbeiten
das hätte weitreichende Konsequenzen
etwa für die Rechte von Minderheiten
hier im Land für die Europa Politik
allerdings wird nicht damit gerechnet
dass eine Partei hier heute Abend eine
absolute Mehrheit bekommt das kann
bedeuten dass es anschließend recht
langwierige koalitionsverhandlung hier
im Parlament hinter mir geben wird
dankeschön
in Israel hat das Parlament mit den
entscheidenden Beratungen über die
umstrittene Justizreform begonnen seit
über einem halben Jahr demonstrieren
hunderttausende gegen den Plan der
Regierung die Rechte des
Verfassungsgerichts bei der Überprüfung
politischer Entscheidungen stark
einzuschränken auch heute gibt es
Protest im ganzen Land Stefan
Protestmarsch von Tel Aviv nach
Jerusalem 60 km Temperaturen über 30
Grad 10 tausende sind es am Ende die ihr
Zelt in der Heiligenstadt aufschlagen
morgen will die rechtsreligiöse
Regierung hier über eine Einschränkung
der obersten Gerichte entscheiden
wir hoffen dass diese Änderung nicht
kommt dass sie dieses Gesetz nicht
durchwinken aber wenn sie es machen dann
müssen wir noch härter kämpfen wir
werden uns nicht der Verrücktheit beugen
die dieses Land ergriffen hat
gegen die sogenannte Justizreform
stemmen sich Hunderttausende mit ihnen
Top-Manager und ehemalige
Geheimdienstchefs und auch Teile des
Militärs hunderte Reservisten
unterschrieben eine Petition tausende
drohen nicht mehr zu dienen
diese Regierung will unbegrenzte Macht
sie glauben dass sie nicht liberale
Regeln und aktivitätenvorschreiben
können und das wollen wir verhindern
die Justizreform seit heute in der
Knesset in den letzten Lesungen will den
Gerichten die Möglichkeit nehmen
Entscheidungen der Regierung zu kippen
wenn diese nicht angemessen erscheinen
zur Stunde demonstrieren hier in Teller
rief die Befürworter der Reform es sind
weit weniger als die Gegner aber die
Stimmung ist auf beiden Seiten
aufgeheizt und beide Seiten warten und
darauf was morgen in der knesse
entschieden werden wird fest steht schon
jetzt hat die Demokratie gelitten wurde
sogar das Militär in die politische
Debatte hineingezogen bisher einmalig in
der Geschichte Israels
morgen wird es ernst für die deutsche
Nationalmannschaft der Frauen und die
ersten drei Punkte sind ja wirklich fest
eingeplant bei der
Fußballweltmeisterschaft
im ersten Gruppenspiel gegen Marokko gut
angekommen in Melbourne nochmal
trainiert die Presse informiert nun kann
es losgehen in Australien mit dem
Projekt WM-Titel Nummer 3
die Vorfreude steht Nationaltorhüterin
Merle froms ins Gesicht geschrieben
beinahe ergriffen im WM Stadion in
Melbourne die Zielrichtung auch bei der
Bundestrainerin eindeutig
eben alles aus uns herausholen und und
wollen natürlich wie auch im letzten
Jahr oder oder eigentlich immer wollen
wir die Menschen mitnehmen wollen sie
emotionalisieren aus der Aufstellung
macht sie öffentlich einen Geheimnis
offenbar bestehen für die angeschlagene
Lena Oberdorf doch Einsatzchancen für
einen wärmeauftakt mit hoffentlich hohem
Erinnerungswert
Deutschland Marokko Anpfiff um 10 Uhr
aber los geht's bei Sportstudio live
Morgen schon um halb acht mit Italien
gegen Argentinien die aktuellen
Ergebnisse von heute Frankreich
enttäuscht beim 0:0 gegen Jamaika
Niederlande Portugal 1:0 Schwedens 2:1
Siegtor gegen Südafrika kurz vor Schluss
auch in Japan ist WM und zwar die im
Schwimmen zum Auftakt der
beckenwettbewerbe gleich mit drei
Weltrekorden dabei unterbietet der
Franzose Leon machère über 400 Meter
Lagen die 15 Jahre alte Bestmarke von
Michael Phelps und tippt damit den
letzten einzelwetterrekord des US
Superstars
und Lukas Mertens hat seine zweite WM
Einzelmedaille Bronze über 400 m
Freistil
Europameister Mertens geht als einer der
Favoriten an den Start doch bald
zeichnet sich ab dass es für den Titel
nicht reichen wird aber hinter dem
Australier Samuel short und Ahmed
hafnerei aus Tunesien schwimmt der
21-Jährige souverän zu Bronze Mertens
ist mit 3 Minuten 42,2 Sekunden mehr als
eine halbe Sekunde schneller als bei
seinem WM Silber im vergangenen Jahr und
hat sich die Qualifikation für Olympia
in Paris gesichert
und das war es vom Sport Dankeschön und
so wird das Wetter
im Osten ist es anfangs noch meist
freundlich sonst sind die Wolken dichter
und von Westen kommen Schauer und teils
kräftige Gewitter auf bei einem
lebhaften Südwestwind werden 20 bis 30
Grad erreicht
Christian Sievers begrüßt sie um 21:45
Uhr zum heute-journal und jetzt geht's
weiter direkt mit Theo Koll und dem
zdf-sommer Interview mit CDU Chef Merz
tschüss
[Musik]